[Music]
on this Sunday night feeling the Heat
beer searing temperatures will fuel
wildfires decimating Canada's Northwest
Territories this is a very serious
situation tonight the battle to save Hay
River as flames race toward the edge of
town
the me too moment engulfing Spanish
soccer it's really created a massive
debate about women's rights and equality
shooting for a culture change after that
scandalous World Cup kiss
reconstruction slows as Canada's housing
crisis grows we are going to see that
impact three four five years down the
road the dampening demand in the
classic how Canada's favorite fall
flavor snowballed into a billion dollar
business
global national with baronessor
good evening to you thanks for joining
us in the Northwest Territories tonight
there is both relief and worry
firefighters have managed to save the
town of Hay River after a wildfire moved
within a kilometer of the community but
a new heat warning and a shift in the
winds is once again putting the region
at risk Environment Canada warns
temperatures could reach 28 degrees
today that's 10 degrees higher than the
normal average for the area and tomorrow
is expected to be even hotter
potentially record-breaking with an
expected high of 31. as Mike Armstrong
reports firefighters are hoping for the
best but they're also preparing for the
worst
the town of Hay River is supposed to be
cleared out the fire is that close even
firefighting Crews were cut down to only
essential workers support staff was
moved South despite the danger it's
believed about a hundred people refused
to leave the fire situation is very
serious if you're there it's not safe
um please if you can arrange a way out
nobody was asking about sprinklers Crews
spent days preparing laying down
defenses in case the fire got close
it did according to the latest update
the Flames made it within a kilometer
and a half of the town center and within
a kilometer of the airport those efforts
definitely paid off the mayor says
without the work that was done the
situation may have been worse fire
breaks and sprinkler systems protected
the town wind conditions helped as well
and allowed Crews to attack from the air
one thing they were nervous they might
lose was the water treatment plant just
north of Hay River it so far has made it
through that was a you know that was a
huge win for the community and that's
what we're doing right now is counting
our wins and being prepared for whatever
comes at us
now close to 70 percent of people in the
Northwest Territories have been forced
from their homes city of Edmonton has
had to stop registering new evacuees
it's placed 3 100 people in hotels twice
the number it expected since leaving
Yellowknife 11 days ago this man and his
family have had to change hotels three
times it's been rough
trying to work with red cross I realize
there's a lot of people and they're
doing their best they're volunteers and
and but it's been it's been a bit of a
struggle good luck guys there are about
200 firefighting Personnel still working
to protect the town of Hay River the
Coast Guard has a ship on great Slave
Lake in case people need to seek Refuge
it's very much a lost Resort everyone
hopes isn't needed
Mike Armstrong Global News
NBC more positive news on that
province's Wildfire front after
residents were forced to flee thousands
of homes in the Kelowna area more than a
week ago many evacuees are now being
allowed to return home this comes as
firefighters make steady progress
pushing back against three different
wildfires in the region Kamal karmali is
in Lake Country BC camel what Remains
the biggest concern for firefighters
right now over there
for the focus of the firefight continues
to be in West Kelowna where Crews
continue to battle the McDougall Creek
Wildfire the good news though is that
the firefighters appear to be winning
more than 1 000 homes have had their
evacuation orders rescinded in the
region in the past 24 hours alone
leaving just over 2 000 properties still
under that evacuation order but for many
who are returning home there is still
the issue of finding clean water and
getting power as Crews work to get
utilities back up and running while the
Wildfire near West Kelowna remains out
of control there has been more success
east of it where the two wildfires in
the City of Kelowna and just north of it
in Lake Country are both considered held
allowing everyone in those two areas to
return to their daily lives but a
warning from fire officials until we get
it under control and we get that
season-inning event it's still it's
still poses a risk what we need to
really put this fire out is we need a
season ending event so we need a big
rainstorm or snowfall and that'll be
that'll be the part where we know that
we're we move past the fire more than
180 structures homes and businesses burn
to the ground this region is normally a
tourist destination but many are still
under evacuation alert choosing to play
it safe and remain closed the past three
days we've been on alert we have decided
to remain closed this weekend
um out of respect for our neighbors who
are still under order restaurants close
Tasting Room has been closed we've just
had online sales but um it's been it's
it's been bad officials will hold
another public briefing Monday hoping to
deliver more good news and allow
hundreds more to return home but they're
also expecting a sharp rise in the
number of structures destroyed still
trying to finalize that count pharah
and Lake Country BC thank you Connell
and Carmel just showed us a closed
Winery the wildfires are taking a toll
on tourism as Ann gaviola explains the
damage can be both structural and
reputational
it's ready to go home
Devastation destruction displacement the
economic ripple effect of wildfires in
BC in the Northwest Territories has
already dealt a massive blow to tourism
during The crucial final summer month of
August the wildfires leave a
long-lasting scar so there's not
something you can rebuild and replace
again for the next season for places
like the lake Okanagan Resort and the
Rio rafting and yoga Resort there will
be the task of rebuilding and in some
cases starting over but salvaging the
reputational damage from harmful
rhetoric is a whole other Beast we saw
earlier in the year New York the state
of New York and the City of New York can
completely smog down with smoke from
Canadian forest fires the smoke has
reached Europe the New York Post in
early June dubbing smoke infested
Manhattan Apocalypse Now the key message
blame Canada people have you know
probably changed their plans in terms of
coming to Canada and hopefully it won't
have too much of an impact longer term
once once this fire season is over
regions in Canada aren't the only ones
grappling with this challenge in Greece
this hotel owner needs to rebuild but
equally important will be convincing
customers to return we in again the
trust the trust from the guests this
Chef in Hawaii still struggling in the
aftermath of what she calls mixed
messages to tourists is very worried
about her community's ability to bounce
back financially places are still
running and all those people still have
their bills to pay and their single
parents and they have mortgages and they
own businesses Canada's national tourism
Association says clear messaging is key
to reputational repair it's making sure
that the communication to uh to
Travelers is accurate and that we
provide as an industry the best
information possible the stakes are high
for areas that depend on their outdoor
Splendor to attract tourists we generate
billions in revenue and support homeless
jobs and so the increased threat of
climate related disruptions such as
wildfires and and severe weather really
jeopardizes that vital economic engine a
pillar of Canada's economy that must
adapt to a new climate reality and
gaviola Global News Toronto
developments today in the wake of last
week's plane crash and the whereabouts
of Wegner Chief evgeny progosian today
Russian authorities sent genetic testing
proves pregosian was killed in the crash
on Wednesday
Russia says genetic testing has been
completed on all 10 bodies recovered
from the crash site and puts to rest any
doubt the pagosian was on board and is
dead but the Kremlin sponsored probe did
not determine why the jet fell from the
sky between Moscow and St Petersburg
there is speculation for Goshen may have
been trying to disappear after staging a
failed coup in June and that a bomb may
have been planted on board or that a
Russian missile was to blame
in Australia three U.S Marines were
killed during a joint military training
exercise in the country's Northern
Territory
our Focus as a government and as a
Department of Defense is very much on
incident response and on making sure
that every support and assistance is
given at this difficult time
Australia's prime minister says it's a
tragedy the U.S Marines were among 23
members on board an mv-22b osprey with a
tilt rotor helicopter crashed over the
remote kiwi Islands everyone on board
was injured
we have new details tonight about
yesterday's hate-fueled shooting in
Jacksonville Florida
the shooter a white man was identified
today as 21 year old Ryan Christopher
palmeter he killed three black people
two men and a woman at a dollar store
before killing himself investigators say
the gunman had no red flags that he had
no previous criminal history and that
his Firearms were bought legally
his sickening ideology is not
representative of the values of this
Jacksonville community that we all love
so much
we are not a community of hate
today investigators laid out a timeline
if the shooting spree and showed the
moment the gunman will enter the dollar
store the shooter left a suicide note
and a Manifesto before carrying out his
racist attack and he wore a bulletproof
vest and was armed with a military-style
rifle and a handgun which had swastikas
drawn on them earlier he had been turned
away from the campus of a historically
black University located nearby
Donald Trump's turn is mug shot into a
fundraising windfall
his campaigns raised over 7 million
dollars since he was booked at a Georgia
jail on Thursday night on Friday alone
the former president brought in over 4
million dollars making it the single
highest 24-hour period of his campaign
to date fundraising has been powered by
merchandise sold through his online
store using the now Infamous mugshots
clouded in controversy coming up the
football Crafters in Spain after that
World Cup final kiss
a watershed moment for women's soccer in
Spain is instead a scandal that's turned
into a movement the Spanish soccer
Federation is now investigating the
behavior of its president Louise
rubialis after he kissed star player
Jenny ermoso on the mouth after last
weekend's World Cup without her consent
Canadian soccer Legend Christine
Sinclair is the latest player to
publicly back or mosto posting that she
stands with these Spanish World Cup
winner Redmond Shannon reports
one week ago Spain's women's soccer team
became world champions for the first
time now instead of Basking in the glory
Spanish soccer is in total chaos every
winning player and dozens more saying
they won't play for their country until
Luis rubiales is removed as Federation
president
stars of the men's game have joined the
condemnation of rubial's kiss on the
mouth of player Jenny hermoso at the
trophy ceremony one she insists was not
consensual it's all anyone can and talk
about it's getting wall-to-wall coverage
from the media it's been like that for
seven days everyone is talking about
this
rubiales was expected to resign on
Friday until a defiant speech that
shocked Spain
I will not resign he repeated applauded
by many colleagues including the women's
head coach that the Federation
threatened to sue hermoso but now it
says it's investigating rubial's conduct
under its sexual violence protocol FIFA
has suspended him for now
and the Spanish government says it will
make sure he doesn't return now it's
really created a massive debate about
women's rights and equality
and how women should be treated and how
normalized all of these behaviors have
been for so long for far too long
Justice Hollywood triggered the original
metoo movement Spain's national
obsession with soccer is doing something
similar Legacy is a much used word at
Major sporting events but for Spain This
World Cup Legacy could be about much
more than sport Redmond Shannon Global
News London
I had Canada's home construction sales
slump
[Music]
its Rising interest rates leave
potential home buyers across this
country in a pinch Canada's largest
population Center is seeing a worrying
slump in real estate sales
according to an industry report last
week the greater Toronto area saw just
under 1200 new home sales in July not
only is that an 18 drop compared to the
same time last year that's half of the
10-year average the number of new
condominium sales is particularly
concerning with a 39 percent decline
from last year from its lowest number
sold for July in 23 years
joining us now is Dave Wilkes president
and CEO of build the building industry
and Land Development Association Dave
thanks for joining us you know we're
seeing a housing crisis in Canada but
we're hearing the developers are hitting
pause on new projects why is that
happening
yes good evening and thank you very much
for the opportunity to uh to share some
insights as to what's going on in the
industry uh we have seen uh not the
projects that are currently underway for
the sales that were taken a couple years
or made a couple years ago but what
we're really seeing is a pause and new
uh new sales and so therefore we're the
construction activity that will be
affected is probably two three four
years down the road but that pause is
really uh caused by two things uh Rising
interest rates and the uncertainty that
that causes and consumers just being on
the sidelines and we're also seeing
tremendous increase in the cost of
building so those two factors are really
making it challenging for new sales
right now and when you're talking about
pre-construction right so in five years
what's this going to mean if we're
pausing pre-construction sales is this
going to make the housing crisis worse
absolutely you nailed it so we are
talking about pre-construction sales
typically a project before you can get
shovels in the ground or the financing
that is required for to move ahead
requires what 80 percent of the units or
the homes to be sold uh that that
dampening of Demand right now or in some
cases you know sales centers aren't even
having folks walk in the door we are
going to see that impact three four five
years down the road that will have both
an impact on the supply of housing but
the jobs that are created by the sector
as well
but you know Dave when you think about
it I mean even if you build these homes
the average person right now can't
afford them so so what is the solution
here
so the the housing crisis uh I I hate to
use that word but there's probably no
better one to describe it uh there's
really a number of things that can be
done to alleviate it uh the federal
government uh can uh incent
purpose-built rental by changing the
treatment of HST uh the for federal and
provincial governments across the
country but particularly in Ontario and
BC can invest in infrastructure to
facilitate land being able to uh be used
for residential uh homes and
construction excuse me and Municipal
governments can look to increase the
approval times that they take it takes
about three years for project to be
reviewed and approved in the city of
Toronto for example that can be speeded
up so far we took many decades to get
into this uh challenge that we currently
have it's going to take some time to get
uh out of it but there are solutions
that are available and we're encouraging
and working with governments to achieve
those Solutions
day Wilkes president and CEO of build
the building industry and Land
Development Association I thank you for
your Insight
thank you very much Katrina pleasure
[Music]
hey turns 20
20.
a massive search is underway in the
Scottish Highlands in an effort to
unravel one of the Earth's Biggest
Mysteries finding the fabled Loch Ness
monster researchers used thermal imaging
drones infrared cameras and an
underwater Hydro phone to detect sounds
in the murky Waters so how did it go
well these budding Monster Hunters said
they heard four distinctive Loops but
then ran into technical difficulties
we all had it it wasn't just me goodness
it was on the speaker system
he ran to go make sure that the recorder
was on uh and it wasn't plugged in and
that was my fault because I tested that
equipment before it came on the boat so
I knew it was working so I didn't turn
it on so when we I know it's classic
classic
so unfortunate still it's been the
biggest hunt for Nessie in more than 50
years
as summer winds down another way to tell
fall is fast approaching is by dropping
into your local Starbucks the pumpkin
spice latte is already back on the menu
the fall inspired drink turns 20 this
year and as Teresa explains the flavor
has fueled a billion dollar industry of
all things pumpkin
for people of a certain age three words
signal the start of autumn pumpkin spice
latte I like the novelty
the fact that it's a short-term thing so
popular it even has its own acronym PSL
I don't like pumpkin fights everything
but this latte yes
I'm basic
Starbucks has been serving the sugary
concoction for exactly 20 years I didn't
know that it was that old but I can see
why I think it's just like a classic a
fall classic released before the summer
even ends
over the decades it's become something
of a cultural phenomenon stirring debate
I'm like I don't get the hype so I'm
like okay cool I hate Pumpkin
love it or hate it the beverage has
changed Coffee Culture and inspired a
huge industry of imitators
pumpkin salsa spam even caviar in the
past year pumpkin flavored products have
made almost a billion dollars in the US
so what's behind the growing appetite
for gourd in the case of Starbucks
seasonal cells they created this
Nostalgia this demand that that surfaces
every fall and they've done a great job
of keeping that going when normally
these types of cultural things die out
you won't find a PSL on this menu coffee
purists are loathed to even call it
coffee have you ever ordered one
yourself oh God no are you kidding but
even its critics can appreciate the
staying power of this polarizing drink
20 years it's it's a long time but
I mean again it's a personal preference
and I think we'll leave it at that as
they say teria isri Global News Ottawa
and ask global national for this Sunday
night I'm Farah Nasser and tonight's
your Canada is one for the history books
as Canada just had its greatest one-day
metal haul ever at the world athletic
championships Pierce LePage won Gold in
the men's decathlon while Damien Warner
took home silver at the same event Sarah
Mitten snags silver in the women's shot
put and Marco erupt bagged a gold medal
in the men's 800 meters congratulations
until next time take care of yourselves
and take care of each other good night
[Music]
thank you